over the weekend the deadly storm system
ravaged communities from Iowa two
tornadoes on the ground to Delaware this
is crazy
around 260 people were inside of this
packed heavy metal concert venue in
Belvedere Illinois Friday when an ef-1
tornado with 100 mile per hour winds
swept through causing the roof to
collapse one person was killed and
dozens of others were injured the death
toll was highest in Tennessee where more
than a dozen people died nine people
were killed in rural McNairy County
in Arkansas a man captured the moment a
tornado swept over his van outside
little rock around 100 miles to the
Northeast the small town of Winn
Arkansas has been reduced to Rubble this
is what's left of Curtis mcnelly's house
this is my son's bedroom he hid from the
tornado in the hallway of his home with
his two kids wife and mother-in-law